alors l'une des sorties incontournables
du week-end à côté c'est du côté de la
vallée de Chevreuse le domaine de
Dampierre-en-Yvelines va rouvrir ses
portes pour une cinquième saison et ce
après environ 4 mois de mise en sommeil
hivernale parce qu'elle te va on sait
alors tout le temps s'est mis en sommeil
c'est aussi une période propice pour
faire des travaux on vous avait reçu sur
ce plateau pour parler de la fin des
travaux et la fin de ce chantier de
restauration du clos et du couvert du
château là le chantier continue aussi à
Dampierre il y a d'autres travaux encore
ça n'arrête pas ça continue il faut
quand même préciser que c'est plus gros
chantier d'Europe en mathématonie sur un
château comme celui-ci qui est destiné à
trouver au public donc moi j'avais
tendance à dire c'était le plus gros
chantier de France et on m'a dit mais
non c'est une Europe et donc on vit une
aventure extraordinaire à Dampierre et
évidemment l'hiver c'est propice pour
faire les chantiers mais on va continuer
même si on ouvre au public à partir de
samedi lundi et en semaine donc du coup
il y a le chantier mais qui est
complètement isolé du public puisque on
a tout sécurisé est mis en valeur ce qui
a été réalisé par les ouvriers cet le
domaine de Dampierre-en-Yvelines on le
rappelle bijou du 17e siècle œuvre de
Jules Ardon Mansart pour le château
André Le Nôtre pour les jardins et le
but depuis le rachat par Francky Mullier
c'est de réveiller cette belle endormie
alors on parle même de belles endormi au
masculin puisqu'on parle du domaine de
Dampierre c'est ça le but aujourd'hui
exactement on mène vraiment cette
politique avec les propriétaires pour
faire connaître à nouveau dans pierre
dans pierre était un monument qui a eu
connu ses heures de gloire jusque dans
les années 80 et puis ça s'est endormi
dans les depuis 40 ans et donc Franck
immobilier était là pour
redonner un nouvel élan à ce domaine à
ce château avec tous ces travaux qu'il
mène à terme j'espère dans deux ans
venir et vous dire ça y est on ouvre le
château pour rentrer dans le château on
pourra rentrer dans le château mais
peut-être que une surprise durant la
programmation pourra rentrer cette année
dans le château un jour c'est je pense
en bonne voie pour que ça puisse se
réaliser et mais surtout c'est faire
connaître on est aux portes de
Saint-Quentin on est à 2 km à vol
d'oiseau et les gens le connaissent
peut-être pas donc du coup notre but est
bien c'est que les Yvelinois et les 5
continents évidemment mais les Yvelinois
viennent découvrir ce havre de paix au
cœur de la Vallée de Chevreuse parce que
quand on est autour du château dans les
jardins on oublie en fait qu'on est aux
portes de l'accès l'agglomération c'est
sa force c'est son cadre
ça promet de belles balades en famille
autour de cette pièce d'eau justement la
pièce Jordan la pièce d'eau toute
différent parcours avec des jeux
d'énigmes qu'on a fait pour les enfants
dans les bosquets donner envie au public
de d'aller plus loin qu'autour de cette
pièce d'eau et de redécouvrir cette ce
patrimoine de jardin patrimoine
architectural et puis cette biodiversité
puisque malgré tout et bien c'est aussi
la biodiversité qui qui s'est développée
parce que quand j'ai 40 ans oui c'est
peu passé de choses et bien au contraire
c'était une un réservoir de biodiversité
qui s'est développé et donc le public et
bien apprécie d'être en contact avec
tous ces oiseaux tous ces animaux qui
sont voilà dans un état où ils se les
espaces sont tellement vaste qu'on peut
les approcher sans les déranger vous
connaissez le domaine de l'Empire en
Yvelines
j'y suis allé avec mon association faire
un email un mariage donc le cadre voilà
le cadre fermé le cadre est excellent
autour du plateau vous êtes déjà allé
sur place je n'y suis jamais allé mais
je pense que ce sera l'occasion vous
êtes un très bon vendeur
c'est vrai donc cette cinquième saison
qui s'ouvre et à chaque nouvelle saison
il y a des nouveautés cette année quels
sont les principales nouveautés alors là
fort avec le printemps puisque le
printemps c'est le premier avril la
chasse aux poissons d'avril puisque le
premier abri c'est un samedi aussi de
Pâques avant la chasse aux œufs de
Pâques et là tout le weekend de Pâques
avec des des cloches géantes avec des
animaux et toujours avec des jeux
d'indices et des cadeaux évidemment
chocolatés pour les enfants ça et puis
le printemps les vacances de printemps
en fait ils se passent rarement des des
choses dans les de les lieux culturels
le lieu patrimoniaux dédié aux enfants
et au public pour des belles promenades
et on va mettre Dampierre avec des
jolies mises en scène de printanières
puisque au printemps le château et bien
on ouvre les fenêtres en étant on fait
le lavage de printemps on des grandes
lessives donc il y aura des draps qui
vont sécher qui vont voler au vent des
nichoirs qui vont permettre d'accueillir
les les mésanges etc donc tout un tout
un thème autour de ce printemps et puis
après dans les grosses nouveautés un peu
plus tard les les belles de Dampierre là
où vraiment c'était une première édition
l'année dernière et là on réunit
un bel ensemble historique de voitures
automobiles et de voitures automobiles
la jonction le passage entre les deux
mais vraiment le des ancêtres
automobiles et les dernières ouvertures
de carrosserie Hippo mobile donc là on
est vraiment sur un beau montage avec
les associations locales autour de
Rambouillet et puis je vais un peu vite
mais cet été art contemporain dans le
jardin de l'anglaise il y aura des
guinguettes j'ai des guinguettes au mois
de juin au mois de juillet parce que
évidemment faire connaître le patrimoine
c'est aussi pouvoir le vivre et vivre
une guinguette c'est danser c'est boire
un verre et une place de chat une
planche de charcuterie ou une planche de
fromage voilà on essaye de vraiment
faire vivre ce domaine c'est vraiment
notre volonté
aussi des QR codes qui ont été disposés
sur il y a des QR code côté disposés sur
parcours avec valorisation de la
biodiversité du patrimoine et puis
prochainement alors là j'ai hâte parce
que c'est des problèmes techniques qui
me bloquent là-dessus mais normalement
sur le site internet les gens qui ont
envie de découvrir le château et bien
pourront faire une visite en
m'accompagnant une visite guidée merci
c'est une petite nouveauté je pense que
je reviendrai à expliquer ça un peu plus
tard quand ça sortira plus vous serez
vraiment curieux et donc on fera une
visite dans le château et là bah voilà
c'est une petite poème technique qui
nous font prendre du retard mais ça va
être sympa on peut suivre l'actualité en
tout cas sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran j'imagine
qu'il y aura toujours les classiques les
balades en calèche en Rosalie les
balades en attelage tirés par Nomi
américaines et la nouveauté c'est que
cette année le propriétaire cet hiver a
installé dans une prairie humide dans
une zone humide pardon il a des Bleus
Island parce que vraiment pour leur
promener un entretien respectueux de
l'environnement donc on a début Island
et au milieu de ces bailand et bien il y
a des biches qui viennent et là même pas
effacer par le public on arrive il y a
des bijoux des bœufs vaillants c'est
vraiment extraordinaire et puis
évidemment les rosalies les Golf 7 les